الاحصائيه الاسرائيليه لاطلاق الصواريخ هي
خمسه اطلاق 25
صاروخا من جنوب لبنان تجاه منطقه الجليل
معظم هذه الصواريخ هي من نوع كاتيوشا
واغراد صواريخ قديما نسبيا اطلقت على
دفعات
عمليا خمسه منها سقطت في اطار المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه الباقيه ساقطت في مناطق
مفتوحه وفي البحر بعد الصواريخ سقطت ايضا
المعلومات الاخيره الراشحه هي ان النتانيو
سيعقد اجتماعا للحكومه الامنيه المصغره
هذا المساء لتحديد ربما الرد الاسرائيلي
على ما يحدث التسريبات الاسرائيليه
المتواتره تتهم الفصائل الفلسطينيه بل
وتسميها تسميها عمليا في لبنان تقول ان
حماس في لبنان هي من اطلقت هذه الصواريخ
هذا ربما يقود الى الاعتقاد بان ثمه ردا
اسرائيليا ولكن قابلا للاحتواء بدون كسر
قواعد اللعبه قد نشد للرد في منطقتين في
قطاع غزه لان الان الاتهام يوجه لحماس وفي
لبنان لان الصواريخ اطلقت من لبنان قد
يكون اطلاق قذائف مدفعيه سؤال كان هناك
تخطيط لما هو اكبر لغارات من المقاتلات او
شيء من هذا القبيل لان هذا عمليا يغير
قواعد اللعبه في الاشتباك عمليه